Comedy and Magic reinvented and so much
fun for the whole family and now you can
catch him at Jimmy Kimmel's Comedy Club
Farrell Dillon joins us welcome Hey
Mercedes thank you for having me it's so
good to have you I've heard so much
about your show I have not been yet I
cannot wait to go oh it's the best it's
so fun every day it's seriously so fun
and it's good for the whole family tell
us a little bit well first of all how do
you like performing here in Las Vegas uh
performing in Las Vegas is amazing and
especially at the new comedy club Jimmy
Kimmel's comedy club is amazing it's
beautiful inside uh the lighting is
gorgeous it's just an awesome room to be
in when did you know you wanted to do
what you're doing I started doing magic
when I was 12. uh my mom got me a little
magic deck of cards and then I put it
away and then one day I was bored I
picked it up and I just started learning
tricks and I was like oh this is the
best thing ever and now you're doing
that for audiences that must be a dream
come true to do it at Jimmy Kimmel's
Comedy Club Jimmy Kimmel's comedy club
and in Las Vegas it's always been the
dream right this is the dream of all
magicians now did you have any big
Inspirations as far as other MIDI
editions is there anything you really
looked up to yeah there's a bunch of
magicians I looked up to one of the main
ones still works here in town Matt King
was probably one of the biggest
influences but also David Copperfield
Yeah and also uh I mentioned him every
night in my show because that's what
made me want to come to Las Vegas is
Lance Burton oh he was so great he was
my favorite magician ever so now what
can people expect from your show uh so
my show is like uh Comedy and Magic
combined so I do a lot of jokes but
mostly it's about the um
the situations right like for me like
the best comedy uh it comes from good
situations so like I love sitcoms on TV
and that's kind of how I like built my
show was around those kind of sitcoms so
we put people and myself in funny
situations and then see what happens
from there well now no visit it would be
complete without showing us a little bit
of what you can do and yeah I see that
you have a deck of cards so I'm glad
that you uh asked what can we do here
I'm gonna do a card trick for you uh but
before I show you the trick I have to
show you something important is this
empty well not that well there's a piece
of confetti in there because you know
it's magic uh but you can uh there's not
empty pocket you can just give a little
honk honk
I just want to I just want to scream in
your face because I'm kind of a jerk but
now look now that we can know the pocket
is empty Mercedes I can begin the trick
for you okay uh go ahead take one look
at it don't let me see it but show it to
the camera oh that's a good one okay
show it to the camera good I'll just
look in the monitor so I can see it
great
you got it right now Mercedes look I'm
oh okay you're still showing them so
he's still showing don't look all right
make sure it's the side with the numbers
or letters all right don't show them the
back okay all right good and then I'll
drop cards from one hand to the other
you say stop somewhere in the middle
okay stop
oh sorry oh look
almost here but
oh Mercedes your card is going to fly
through the air and land in my pocket
are you ready how's that even possible
I see nothing boom one card from here
two here
yep that was it
what no your card was the nine of space
right no it was not okay good cause I
got the Joker oh my gosh oh my gosh is
that it yes that was it you want me to
show you how it works so first what you
got to do you gotta make sure somebody
picks the Joker then you put it in the
middle you turn it invisible you take it
out and you stuff it down in your pocket
while it's invisible that's how it works
so watch The Joker it goes in the middle
here push it all the way in
look I riffle the cards I take it out
it's invisible I put it down inside my
pocket once it hits the pocket it turns
visible again see what is happening okay
one more one more time one more time
okay I don't want you to think I'm
cheating right I don't want you to think
that oh there's like a mechanical device
that pulls the card up his sleeve across
this manly chest muscles no down is on
the sleeve so here's what I need from
you just take your little pinch of
fingers go to the top of the pocket pull
out the card well not yet no I haven't
done the thing but now I know you'll do
it I'm excited and that's what's
important so look I Rubble the cards
take it out put it inside the pocket go
ahead check it out dude I'm just kidding
it's weird no you don't reach inside
people's pockets Mercedes plus if you
did you would have found this other
Joker but this one's got color on it so
hold on to that that's not it here you
would have also found this one right
here this is the thing oh my gosh I
gotta wrap you this is crazy it's on all
the cards except for this one it didn't
fly to my pocket and that just so
happens to be your card The Joker you
can check out
from Thursday Thursday or to Monday at 4
30 p.m at Jimmy Kimmel's Comedy Club
tickets at Kimball's comedy club.com